[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
raconte moi quand tu étais un pays que
j'aime à dire je me sall et c'est
beaucoup il fallait bien que je fasse ma
lessive alors je fais un peu de
toilettes parce que je vais voir
bérénice à un petit coup sur la crinière
mt coup parfait et un petit coup par là
haut
qu'est ce que cette femme
ça ne part pas c'est une tasse ou
abreuvant bien fort elle va peut-être
disparaître et n'y a rien à faire
un tiens bien mon pantalon est passé et
perret mm pas faim et venez qu'un seul
pantalon temps puis vevey le laver dans
le petit paquet
une bonne lessive voilà ce qu'il lui
faut j'en ai pour cinq minutes
en frottant bien mon pantalon sera lp
table c'est amusant de faire la lessive
et puis en même temps on se lave bien
les pattes
c'est un graphique à la sas est parti à
présent dans lève le tabou par un petit
rinçage à l'eau claire et les communes
je vais le mettre à sécher nouvelle et
tendre ici personne ne le verra dans ce
coin voilà vous viendrait le chercher
quand il sera sec
je vous ferai propres pour aller voir
des rennais en attendant je vais
préparer les croissants de vos lits
petit 300 hommes pour bérénice et un
pour moi
titus titus catastrophe à ses pires et
nice qui vient ici je parle à qui tu es
c'est bérénice et je suis 100 en talons
hauts à la ralalala fait pas possible on
va à mais il ne faut pas qu'elle me voit
comme ça tu ne veux pas me voir
aujourd'hui
mais voyons titus arrête-toi recettes
bérénice al-kourbi dans le drame en
attraper arrête tu suis là je le sais ce
n'est pas la peine de te cacher mais bob
lubbers nf bonomo cas graves
alors puisque tu ne te cache pas montre
toi devant moi non il ne verra pas tu
n'avais pas m'attendre dans tapoter mais
je t'ai attendu si tu n'es pas venu
alors c'est moi qui viens et c'est comme
ça que tu me reçoit eh bien tu as titus
je retourne chez moi
bern et bern où on tu ne peux pas
comprendre quelqu'un c'est la lessive
ici le pantalon de titus je comprends
tout à présent pauvre tus
il n'a qu'un pantalon il a lavé billy
sic je vais le lui apporter les parties
les très frais elle ne veut plus me voir
au
tout ça parce que je l'avais mon année
pantalon têtu tu es encore là tu es
revenu alors tu ne pas parfait non titus
je t'annonce que tu allais fidesz tâche
aux peureux nous tu me comprend neuf pas
jeu city n'en parlons plus
toi aussi tu vas prendre soin voilà vous
suivrai titus impeccable et long terme
en laver à la main
c'est comme ça que j'aime les millions
[Musique]
je crois que je vais faire mal et fit
plus souvent et un trait après bête une
autre étoile